the UN Special Envoy Martin Griffiths
believes the threat of kovat 19 may have
started to focus minds in Yemen
he told members of the UN Security
Council in a videoconference meeting
that he'd had productive negotiations
about a new peace deal that would
include a nationwide ceasefire over the
past two weeks or more since then I have
been in constant negotiations with the
parties on the texts of these agreements
on the detail on the wording of these
agreements we expect them to agree on
and formally adopt these agreements in
the immediate future
this positive news comes amid many dire
warnings for Yemen the existing
humanitarian ceasefire in the port of
heard Aida now 60 months old is being
violated in an almost daily basis if
kovat 19 was to spread through the
country it would cause devastation in
part ambassadors were told because the
UN is running out of money for its
humanitarian work of the UN's 41 major
programs 31 will start closing down in
the next few weeks
if we cannot secure additional funds
this means we will have to start
eliminating many of the activities that
may offer Yemenis the best chance to
avoid kovat 19:1 Security Council
Ambassador told me it was clear there
was much at stake right now we have
already information that the virus has
reached Yemen the first case is already
there and and I think it's really high
time for both sides and especially the
Houthis who have not accepted the
ceasefire to go ahead and think about
the future and to think about the
population that is going to suffer even
more UN envoy griffith said Yemen can't
afford to fight on two fronts at once
he's hoping diplomacy can finally bring
an end to the conflict so the focus can
move to fighting the virus James BAE's
al Jazeera
at the United Nations